and
[Applause]
not this year we beat farmer this year
we beat farmer this year and it mattered
we're going to change people's lives
how you doing internet i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report it's september
6 2022 and that cold open was the
elderly man pretending to be president
emoting he is very angry now at big
pharma even though he's loved big pharma
and we were supposed to about a big
pharma and big pharma is supposed to
tell us how to live and when to leave
our houses and all of that stuff he's
also emotionally disregulated and
crumbling in front of our eyes
that's not even what the show's about
today i just thought it was funny when
he has these emotional outbursts i just
think it's kind of amusing to put in
there i hope you had a great three day
weekend i'm feeling very refreshed and
uh also back in the groove you know it
was kind of funny week for me last week
because uh september 1st the the on the
grid show was thursday and then we did
one show friday and then it was a
three-day weekend it's like i need a
little time to get in the flow it's like
if you put down the basketball for a
couple years you need a little dribbling
before you get in the game so this is
the week where we get back in the game
but my thoughts are clear and i did have
when i was off the grid a little time
although it was mostly changing diapers
and feeding a child
i did have a little time to reflect on
why i do this show and what i'm trying
to get across here and how do we get out
of this madness because you all know it
it's very obvious to me after a month
off the grid it's like so the mar-a-lago
raid happens more irs agents now they're
armed all of these things the descent to
hell keeps coming there was nothing that
i really saw out of the august
disappearance uh when i came back that
showed me oh there's like good moments
happening here now there are there are
pockets there are blips of good moments
there's a lot of them here in florida
one for example would be that ron
desantis well he ran uncontested in his
own primary
but that florida's becoming solidly a
red state this is a good thing but sort
of at the national level the descent to
the insanity uh continues and i think we
have to figure out some other ways to
fight it uh so we'll be exposing some of
the nonsense today and discussing some
of the ways that uh you can be empowered
in the madness so the theme really today
is that biden
i i believe at this point joe biden is
the worst president in american history
and it's not just for all the obvious
reasons the economy and the supply chain
and all of the stuff right the fact that
you try to order a couch and it takes
six months it's not just that it's also
that he's not really president and we
keep pretending that he's president so
everyone's very angry over his speech
you know or half the country's angry
over his speech which was perhaps the
worst speech ever given by a sitting u.s
president but it's like i don't know
that i could be angry at him really he
doesn't know what he's saying he's just
reading it poorly and then they're angry
at the remember the red backdrop and it
had all these palpatine vibes and it's
like all right well you know
should we be angry at that that they do
it that way or is it intentional and
should we know it's intentional that
they're trying to scare the hell out of
us and what do we do
so yes he's a hypocrite he wants to
bring us together also hates half the
people but pointing out the hypocrisy is
not enough you must do more i have some
thoughts on that
and before we get to it let's talk about
super beats real quick if you're like me
you love finding easy ways to support a
healthy routine i love my super beats
heart shoes and the same people just
came out with my new favorite way to
tackle post-workout inflammation tart
cherry gummies tart cherry gummies from
the makers of super beats heart shoes
are an easy way to reduce inflammation
from exercise and support your metabolic
health the gummies are made with a
clinically studied tart cherry extract
that is up to 40 times more concentrated
than many other tart cherry extracts i
love eating tart cherry gummies after i
hit the gym or go on a run they're truly
the best right now you can get up to 35
off tart cherry gummies plus free
shipping at mytartcherry.com
ruben this is their best offer available
anywhere that's my chart
my tart cherry say that three times fast
my tart cherry dot com slash reuben for
up to 35 off tart cherry gummies my tart
cherry.com slash ruben all right so
let's talk about biden and remember i
think you always have to remember this
going forward when you're talking about
biden
you're kind of not talking about biden
you're talking about who's behind by it
and you're talking about who's pulling
the strings you're talking about who's
giving the optics of the scary red
background um but
he's the guy that's up there right he's
the guy with the facelifts and the hair
plugs and the fake teeth he's the guy
that's up there that's doing the thing
so we call joe biden the president of
the united states but his pattern of
dishonest and dangerous rhetoric is
really insane because so much of it is
done
at the same time in one's speech so
first off before we get into that speech
from last week because i want to unpack
it a little bit more he is a chronic
liar
he is a liar and an idea thief actually
some of you of a certain age may
remember that he tried to run for
president back in like 88 i think it was
and he had to
end his campaign because of plagiarism
so this is a guy who's been doing this
for years he's also been in government
for 47 years before he was president but
now he's going to fix everything it's
rather extraordinary i don't know what
he was doing for those first 47 years
anyway here he is this past weekend
lying about his history with the civil
rights movement
i got elected to i got very engaged
in my case the civil rights movement
and
as a kid
i was i worked a lot in the movement and
worked and i got deeply involved
in the democratic party because the
democratic party in delaware was a
southern democratic party then
we were
more a southern state than
a northeastern state and i got involved
and one thing led to another
and uh
one day a group came to me of the senior
members of the party and said they
wanted me to run for the senate
okay so joe biden big civil rights hero
that's odd i mean he did give the eulogy
to robert byrd remember robert byrd
former head of the kkk sure he gave the
eulogy at his funeral but okay he was
always marching with the civil rights
people and doing all this civil rights
stuff despite despite the fact that
delaware was kind of a southern state or
something like that well actually for
years people have been debunking the
nonsense that joe biden was out there as
a young man on the lines marching and
doing all this civil rights stuff this
is cnn back in 2019 debunking some of
the nonsense uh he lied to voters
according to the new york times uh
quoting aids of bidens about having
marched in the civil rights movement
this is biden
making this false claim in 1987.
when i marched in the civil rights
movement
i did not march with a 12-point program
i marched with tens of thousands of
others to change attitudes
in the new york times reports quote more
than once advisers had gently reminded
mr biden of the problem with this
formulation he had not actually marched
during the civil rights movement and
more than once mr biden assured them
that he understood and kept telling the
story
anyway that is really really weird
that's two years ago that's jake tapper
who's a democrat who i'm told it's
having uh some problems over there at
cnn it sounds like his job
might be up for grabs um but that's them
before he was president debunking some
of his lies and he's been doing these
lies for decades now what's more
interesting to me about his lies now is
i don't i think i think he actually
believes his lies i think he's lied for
so long that he believes his lies but i
also think he's so mentally compromised
that they can put literally anything and
i mean literally literally they can put
literally anything in front of him and
he'll read it and believe it and that's
why
his emotions when he's speaking are so
disregulated his body motions his
yelling the random turns it's all
breaking down right in front of us but
what a perfect
vessel what a perfect vessel to usher in
the nonsense right like if you were if
you were a shadowy uh group of people or
you were say the obama people or
whoever's in charge wouldn't you want
just a mentally compromised buffoon
who's been lying and pager plagiarizing
his whole life who's of a certain age
now so he doesn't have his full
faculties there so you could keep
putting him out there without him even
realizing that he's the sacrificial lamb
and that he's dead man walking in
essence it would be pretty perfect like
it wouldn't get more
perfect than that but this dishonest way
that he does this uh this lying about
where he was and when he was there and
what he believes i mean who knows what
joe biden believes that's why when i say
he's the worst president it's like who
knows
who's in charge or anything it's like
what are you everyone watching this
right now comment in the comment section
down below i'll respond in the locals
comments particularly obviously
it's like what do you think joe biden
honestly believes like you could look at
donald trump and you could say here are
some things that he obviously believes
he i think he believes america is
fundamentally good let's say you can
look at ron desantis and you can have a
long list of things that it's very
obvious that he believes it what do you
think joe biden honestly believes in
it's actually impossible to say it's
completely impossible to say and we're
going to shift over to more of that
speech because the more i sat on it over
the weekend
the more i started thinking this really
was one of the most insane speeches if
not as i said earlier the most insane
speech that a sitting president has ever
given uh before we get to that let's
talk about real estate agents i trust
you know buying or selling a home is
already one of the most stressful things
you can do and it can be way worse if
you're not working with the right agent
generally our homes are our biggest
investment which is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously which is why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their network and they only
work with full-time pros no part-time or
inexperienced agents their team makes
the introduction then follows you
through the buying or selling process to
make sure that you're satisfied they the
agents they work with have long track
records they're the best sellers in
their field they're part of this
audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just go over to real estate agents
itrust.com and provide them with some
basic info they'll contact you to make
the introduction to the preferred agent
in your town and you live happily ever
after probably in florida
all right let's continue with joe biden
because okay he gives this speech last
week we covered it a little bit you've
seen a lot of the speech the clips but i
want to show you the way that he flips
on a dime because it's it's really
dangerous but it is by design say one
thing then say the complete opposite act
one way then act completely the opposite
so first here's joe biden saying the
stuff that joe biden was elected for to
bring people together and he's a nice
guy and an elderly man and he's you know
into the united states and stuff like
that
i said i was running for three reasons
one to restore the soul of america by
that i meant decency honor
meaning what you say literally treating
people with some respect
okay so that's him this weekend
reiterating what he was saying because
he was starting to get a little pushback
for some of the other
uh
other comments that we'll get to in just
a sec that we're in that speech but
here's a little more from the speech
itself uh he's bringing us together
people
that's why tonight
i'm asking our nation to come together
unite behind the single purpose of
defending our democracy regardless of
your ideology
all right honor respect we're coming
together america it's pretty good good
things are happening
here's just a moment later in the same
speech
too much of what's happening in our
country today is not
normal
donald trump and the migrant republicans
represented extremism
that threatens the very foundations of
our republic
now i want to be very clear
very clear up front
not every republican not even the
majority republicans are maggie
republicans
not every republican embraces their
extreme ideology
i know
because i've been able to work with
these mainstream republicans
but there's no question
that the republican party today is
dominated driven and intimidated
by donald trump and the migrant
republicans
and that is a threat to this country
donald trump and the maggot republicans
ultra magga okay so what does he mean
when he says that donald trump and the
maga republicans and that they're
extremists now let's go back to i don't
know say two years ago
and maybe the previous four years where
donald trump was president and the
economy was cooking
the world was an extremely peaceful
place uh there was a lot of good things
happening we had lowest all-time black
unemployment lowest all-time latino
unemployment
until the democrats decided not only
with covid but with racial justice peace
and harmony to burn down our cities and
it was they
who did it so what he's also doing there
is it's an interesting little linguistic
or or stylistic trick because what he's
saying is there are these donald trump
and maga republicans and those are bad
guys those are bad guys but then there
are good republicans and what he means
by good republicans is what i always
call pet republicans this is mitt romney
liz cheney these people who can come on
to
cnn and msnbc bash republicans the
entire time never conserve anything
never actually accomplish anything but
then they get pat on the head because
they attack republicans and they're good
work well with democrats and they get a
cookie and then they go on so the media
then loves them so really what he's
trying to do is put just this massive
wedge in the republican party
now what i've been trying to fight for
for quite some time obviously is sort of
a wide tent conservatism a wide a wide
tent uh republican party where you can
have uh you know some more libertarian
leaning people like me you guys know the
drill and you're gonna have some more
social conservatives and you're gonna
have libertarians and ex-libs and all
this stuff that's that's what america is
all about actually that's the biggest
threat to that elderly man pretending to
be president uh so on one hand he's
telling you oh you know i'm gonna be the
peace and love president and we just
have to get back that and then on the
other hand he's saying everyone who's
actually my ideological opponent is an
insurrectionist or is an extremist or
something like that so anyway after that
horrific speech and and the the optics
of it that were just awful and
everything and again i think the optics
were by design people kept saying oh who
was in charge of that red wall and it
was so scary and it looked very hillary
and blah blah blah it was like boy they
really dropped the ball on that one it's
like no it's by
design they are incompetent buffoons but
they're not that big of incompetent
buffoons it's by design okay so anyway
they started getting some pushback over
the last couple days on this like man
that was pretty bad like even even
regular folks were seeing it so our uh
black lesbian press secretary corrine
jean-pierre
was asked whether biden owes some people
an apology after that debacle so
in his pre-battle house minority leader
kevin mccarthy among many things he said
he took great issue with a lot of the
things you were just talking about those
legislative accomplishments but he also
said the president owes half the country
an apology that's the president i'll say
this
look the president was very clear all
you have to do again folks need to watch
his speech go read the speech if you
have it it is empowerful it is impactful
and you will hear directly from the
commander-in-chief what he was speaking
to
i mean she says nothing that's the point
right she says absolutely nothing and
that's what she's a master at i really
didn't believe that there could be a
worse press secretary
and someone more dishonest than uh jen
saki but jean crenpierre really does it
jen saki was sort of calculating in her
in her [ __ ] in essence uh this one
is just she's just a wordsmith of
nothing it's just she just says words to
get to the end of the sentence and hopes
that you forget what uh you've asked her
already uh but the point is enough
people are pushing back enough people
are going boy you know you demonized
half the country in essence so let's say
uh let's go with joe biden's logic there
right so 74 million people voted for
trump now he's saying there those are
the bad people but i guess some of them
they're just regular republicans they're
not crazy maga republicans so i don't
know let's say it's only let's say the
base of the trump mega underworld is 20
million people
it's still a lot of people and you do
owe those people an apology joe uh
because they're not bad people and when
you talk about their extremism what is
it that you're talking about as i said
earlier are you talking about that they
had a country uh that was standing up
for itself that was renegotiating deals
all over the world so that uh we weren't
getting screwed and paying for
everything uh that we had things like oh
what was that thing middle east peace
that was pretty good like a whole bunch
of stuff what do you mean they're
extremists what you mean is
they are not democrats they are not
socialists they are not endlessly giving
you more money and power because that's
actually what you want
and of course none of it bears anything
close to being true i'll show you some
we've got this great uh compilation
video we're going to show you just a sec
real quick let me talk to you guys a
little bit about the blaze my friends
over at the blaze as you all know i was
totally gone off the grid in august
larry elder gave me a rundown and all of
that of all the stuff that happened
while i was away and it was a ton
was i surprised to hear that zuckerberg
helped the fbi aka the government manage
the hunter biden laptop story no not
really were you was i surprised here
that gavin newsom is continuing to
destroy california with near laughable
measures no not really were you think of
msnbc like california and blaze tv like
florida or texas you'd have to be crazy
to believe california will suddenly see
and admit to the error of their ways for
the same reason you'd be you'd have to
be crazy to think that msnbc will ever
be fair and report news without a rabid
left-wing agenda that's why blaze tv
matters it's the media network for
americans who actually love the country
has found it crazy i know it's where
people can say what needs to be said
without the fear of censorship you guys
know how strongly i believe in free
speech blaze tv supports free speech the
way the founding fathers intended so
this weekend this week only blaze tv is
offering a 20 discount off the first
year of a blaze tv subscription we're
heading into the midterms you're going
to want news from a network that isn't
run by democrats or spouses and
democrats use promo code ruben 20 for 20
off your first year subscription to
blaze tv it's time to normalize free
speech ain't it
that is the truth okay so let's go a
little bit more into the hypocrisy of
this administration and how on one hand
they tell you and they were voted in and
we heard this i heard this from all of
my good liberal friends biden is not an
extremist he's an elderly man who will
bring the country together
but it just isn't the case that they're
the ones ushering in the extremism
they're the ones who ushered in the
extremism when they were using their
foot soldiers to burn down our cities
here is video of biden advisor keisha
lance bottoms there's a name keisha
lance bottoms
and she is making it quite clear about
what she thinks of people who don't like
joe biden
i see words of encouragement i see
optimism i see a commander-in-chief who
is calling out to all of us no matter
our political affiliation all of us he
wasn't calling out to the manga
supporters certainly he mentioned them
more than a dozen times and as a threat
to democracy has the president
essentially given up on those maga
republicans some 70 million people well
what the president has done is said that
he will continue to work with mainstream
republicans that he will work with
democrats that he will work with
independents to get things done in our
country but this mega-republican agenda
this hate-fueled agenda this
mega-republican agenda that we saw
incite violence on our nation's capital
has no place in a democracy and if we
are not intentional about calling it out
which is what the president did
then our country everything that our
country is built upon is in danger
isn't it incredible they never tell you
what this extremist agenda is i can only
go by what the guy did for four years
and it was pretty pretty good right and
i say that as a guy that didn't even
vote for him that first time okay
so what is so they just keep saying it
they keep repeating it joe biden will
work with anyone you know what's funny
donald trump would have worked with
absolutely anybody and he did when he
was president actually we just posted uh
the full video uh is up right now on
locals and i think the rest of it will
be on rumble and youtube this week my
interview with jared kushner who's the
president's obviously his son-in-law who
ushered in the middle east peace deals
and also was a senior advisor and i
asked him about that and he basically
said trump was willing to work with
anyone to get anything accomplished and
usually they would just hang up the
phone or not take the call clip one will
be up on youtube and rumble today the
full thing as i said is up on locals
already absolutely ad free oh at 1 15
today uh clip will clip one if my
interview with jared will be up anyway
listen to what they say so it's these
mega republicans
who are violent
they are extremists and all sorts of
stuff well i saw this incredible
compilation video check this out remind
me about the violent extremists hmm
donald trump and the migrant republicans
represented extremism
that threatens the very foundations of
our republic
maggie republicans do not respect the
constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
they do not recognize the will of the
people when they fan the flames of
political violence
that are a threat
to our personal rights
to the pursuit of justice
to the rule of law
to the very soul of this country they
embrace anger
they thrive on chaos
the willingness to engage in political
violence is fatal to democracy
more and more talk about violence
as an acceptable political tool
go home
there is no place
for political violence in america period
none ever
[Applause]
you know it's interesting phoenix my
producer just said something interesting
to me during that he said it's textbook
orwell it's weird to see in real life
but what a great juxtaposition of the
language of the left versus the action
of the left where was joe biden and all
the democrats when they were burning
down all the cities when i lived in los
angeles and a mob literally went by my
house and people knew where i lived
and all of that stuff where where were
they on that were they calling for calm
uh or were they screaming more about
black lives matter and antifa and
fueling the flame by the way whatever
happened to black lives matter did they
ever solve any of the problems oh it
turns out that the leader of black lives
matter i think he came out this weekend
he embezzled like 10 million bucks
so they are the ones who have used
violence and that doesn't excuse any
violence that may or come out of the
right right if on january 6 you did
something illegal and you broke
something you burned something down or
something
okay fine i i believe in equality so
anyone that breaks the law should be in
trouble but everything that joe biden
just accused the magga the dark magga
republicans of is exactly what his foot
soldiers have been doing so what do you
do people because as i said to larry
elder
the other day
it is not enough to call out the
hypocrisy we could do this every day for
the rest of my life i could do this i
could just keep this live stream going
until the earth ends have you guys got
anything to do for the rest of eternity
we could just keep this stream going and
every few minutes one of these guys
could hand me a piece of paper holy cow
our background's freaking out what's
going on over there we're freaking
all right i'm gonna just babble for a
moment while i'm doing that this is what
would happen this is actually what would
happen if uh if i just kept talking
forever don't worry we're gonna get our
background there we go i feel much more
like myself again we could call out the
hypocrisy all the time right we could do
it forever but it would not be enough so
what would be enough to get us out of
that slow descent to hell i'm always
talking about well you know what it is
it's conviction
it's saying what you believe and saying
it clearly it's action doing something
about it and occasionally it's comedy
right making fun of these people so that
you can show people what the truth is so
where is that happening people well yeah
it's happening right here in the free
state of florida uh here is governor ron
desantis
sharing his thoughts on joe biden's
speech
well i thought it was one of the most
disgusting speeches an american
president has ever given he ran as being
a unifier and he's basically saying to
the vast majority of the country that
disapproves of him uh that they're
effectively a threat to the republic he
dotters he lashes out but at the end of
the day his policies are why there's so
much opposition to him he came in and he
opened the border and we've seen what a
disaster that's been he kneecapped
american energy we've seen how that's
hurt millions and millions of people
across our country they've inflated the
currency we have one of the worst
inflations we've had in over 40 years so
of course people are going to be upset
at all the wreckage that he's left in
his wake he is the american nero he's a
failed leader and i think that he is
doing this because he's trying to
energize his base to fend off a real
butt whip in this november
that's what you do you state your case
clearly with facts so i want to address
the three things the three specific
bullet points that governor desantis
said there and let's just compare
reality versus what joe biden is talking
about so first off ron desantis calls
him out on the border well we know you
guys know we've covered it many times
here we have had more border crossings
in a shorter period of time than any
other point in american history
certainly american modern history and we
know that the democrats basically want
it right and when trump tried to do
something about it he was called a
racist so
then what happens is they get all these
illegals here they go to these
democrat-run cities like new york and
d.c and then what happens their social
services start collapsing and then the
mayors like muriel bowser in dc is very
upset because her homeless shelters
which are pretty packed anyway because
of her policies are now doubly packed
because they've got a bunch of illegal
immigrants there well what happens when
you send these illegal immigrants who
should not be in this country
to places like florida we bus them to
d.c you gotta love it it's actually
quite spectacular so of course
ron desantis clearly is saying the truth
you guys open the border people are
pissed about it just look what's going
on with voting uh the latino vote in
texas which is now going further and
further to the right and to
conservatives because they've had it
with illegal immigrants the people who
came here legally then energy well we
know this we know this what was the
first thing that joe biden did in
essence you know one of his day one
things when he became president canceled
the keystone xl pipeline they are
intentionally they're telling us that we
are intentionally trying to destroy
fossil fuels we want all of you schmucks
to buy electric cars we don't care how
expensive they are go out and get an
electric car that's what gay pete said
and then of course inflation well you
spend crazy amounts you put in these
crazy bills all of this lunacy money you
just print endlessly and then i'm not a
math a magician but then the value of
money goes down inflation goes up that's
how it works so ronda scientist clearly
states all of those things what's also
interesting about that is
i wonder what joe biden would say about
ron desantis whether he's a dark maga
republican or not now desantis is a guy
who has run this state extremely well
competently gotten critical race theory
out of our schools getting rid of the
gender nonsense our our restaurants and
our economy here absolutely packed
everywhere you go you can feel the
spirit of freedom and of life and you
don't see masks anywhere and all of that
stuff right so is that a good enough
republican for for joe biden um i think
not i think not and i think we'll see
more of that coming but okay so ronda
sanders lays out truth well what else
what also should you do you've got to
have conviction you have to actually
fight and do things because the monster
and the machine is not going to stop uh
here in this case uh here's desantis
actually doing something while biden's
fda is cracking down on
us
after 630 days you know we still sit
here waiting for an answer and so it's
our view that we've waited long enough
and so today we're taking action the
state of florida has now filed a lawsuit
against the fda
they have unlawfully withheld and
unreasonably delayed approval of
florida's program and we think this
violates federal law so we're
[Applause]
damn straight man yeah you sue the
federal government when they don't do
what they're supposed to do or when they
actually overstep what they're supposed
to do which in this case they're they're
often doing both right uh and then
what's the other way you do this so okay
you call it out
then you fight and you also just mock
the [ __ ] out of these people because
that's exactly what they're worthy of
with
with biden
you think of a guy
staring into the teleprompter like a
deer in a headlights
end of quote repeat the line
now i i must say
he did test positive for covid and i
want to on behalf of the state of
florida
wish president biden a speedy recovery
from covet
and i also want to wish the united
states of america a speedy recovery from
joe biden
all right there you go a little humor
related to all of this that's good and
then you know what happens if you state
your case clearly if you have conviction
and you fight if you do a little humor
every now and again you know what
happens people start seeing it they
start seeing it and they start flocking
to the places where truth still exists
where freedom still exists and they
start leaving the places where the lies
and big government and the endless suck
of your money and your attention are all
happening and that's happening in quite
a beautiful way i love this story this
this is going on top the top of the list
of stories that dave rubin loves
this is from the daily wire get this
people a trust linked to the family of
california democratic governor gavin
newsom has donated thousands of dollars
to florida republican governor ron
desantis amid the political feud between
the two governors
fox news reported that records show that
the siebel family revocable trust which
is run by ken siebel jr and judith
siebel the parents of newsome's wife
jennifer siebel gave 5 000 bucks to the
friends of ron desantis pack in early
april the revelation comes as newsom's
reelection campaign bought approximately
105 000 in cable television ads that
aired on fox news in florida last month
claiming that freedom was under attack
in the sunshine state so first off
obviously i've got to put a little money
in here because i'm mentioning
california and we are going to give some
money away to uh california who wants to
move to the free state of florida at the
end of the year but do you realize how
beautiful this is that gavin newsom
soulless devil worshiping gavin newsom
his wife's family
is donating
to
ron desantis his wife's parents have a
place in naples okay they don't want to
be anywhere near his disastrous policies
and have his policies been disastrous
yes from beat one gavin newsom is the
worst of the worst he is a liar and a
fraud and he is anti-science and what he
is pro he is pro-control that's what he
is uh here's newsome back in may of 2020
and he is freaking psyched because
they're locking that [ __ ] down
i think some schools will not be many
schools will be and it's all conditioned
on our ability to not only keep our
children safe but to keep staff and
faculty safe to see the community
safe so it's all predicated
on data on science
not just observed evidence the reality
on the ground
each part of california is unique and
distinct of each region each region of
the united states is unique and
distinctive in certain conditions will
present themselves favorably some
unfavorably so i think it's a it's a
question uh that is a difficult one to
answer in absolute terms there's nuance
uh but we are moving forward in hope and
expectation uh that we can start that
school year very strategically and
methodically again based upon the health
uh as a prime frame of reference in
terms of those decisions
allow me to quote myself gavin newsom is
an evil soulless devil worshiper uh yeah
that's the only way i can put it uh he
kept the schools closed he destroyed the
economy of california hundreds of
thousands of people have fled he is the
number one u-haul uh rental sales guy in
the country because all sorts of people
like me oh and her and this guy and that
guy everyone in this room and a couple
people downstairs right now all fled we
were all uh good tax-paying citizens of
california and we all got out of that
dystopian nightmare uh to move to the
free state of florida because of this
guy and now his wife's freaking parents
are donating to the guy that he hates
most but what else has gavin newsom done
i mean he he's always saying the nice
things he puts a lot of gel in his hair
he must be doing something good for that
state well here's what's going on over
in l.a
in los angeles county more than 60 000
people are homeless on the average night
and more than 20 000 hotel rooms lie
empty on the average night see where
this might be going it's it's just it's
insane um it it isn't going to solve the
problem we think this is one part of the
solution by no means do we think this
solves a homelessness crisis but do
hotels have a role to play of course
they do
so the union he leads which reps hotel
workers gathered enough signatures and
angelinos will vote on a bill that would
force
every hotel in town to report vacancies
at 2pm every day then
welcome homeless people into those
vacant rooms
oh my god do hotels have some role to
play in this of course homeless people
should have room service filet mignon
and massages
god these people have added la have out
of california that's your mayor these
are the people you voted in enjoy it you
freaks but what else is going on in cali
man i'm in a good mood today here a
little more you know what
15
15 american dollars it's only worth
seven dollars now thanks to joe biden
that's going right in the jar right
there okay uh what else is going on in
california well the place is burning
down and they don't have any energy
here's a quote from bloomberg california
narrowly avoided implementing rotating
outages on monday while officials warned
that the state's power grid will face a
bigger test on tuesday that's tomorrow
amid a record-breaking heat wave no
that's today sorry the state's grid
operator canceled its grid emergency
late monday evening after deploying
supplies that helped keep the lights on
even as electricity used soared to its
highest level in five years the prospect
of outages underscores how grids have
become vulnerable in the face of extreme
weather as they transition from fossil
fuels to renewable energy california has
aggressively closed natural gas power
plants in recent years leaving the state
increasingly dependent on solar farms
that go dark late in the day just as
electricity demand peaks at the same
time the state is enduring its worst
drought in 1200 years sapping hydropower
production so people need more power at
night for ac they're turning on lights
etc etc and you're not going to believe
this solar power
needs that light that thing up there
that people used to worship the sun
these people are all backwards morons
complete idiots all of laguna beach okay
laguna beach one of the most beautiful
places in the united states their power
grid went out yesterday for seven hours
it's one of the richest places i've been
to laguna to some fancy freaking houses
with some rich people but rich morons at
this point if they still live in laguna
beach restaurants lost power grocery
stores lost power etc etc so have at it
so do you see the theme of today's show
they lie and everything they do is
backwards and wrong and then there are
some people out there saying the truth
and doing it right it's odd we're not
having rolling blackouts here in florida
it is hot it's humid you know what about
that humidity getting in the electrical
wires or something you know
all right we got a cold clothes for you
in just a moment i want to get to some
comments from the locals community i
also just want to give a quick shout out
to the locals community because
now that i'm back i might all i've been
doing this for quite some time but i'm
doubling down on it all of my
interaction i'm not interacting with
people anywhere else it is all on locals
and i love reading the comments every
day and i've been sharing a little bit
more of the personal
stuff and what's going on with justin
and being a new dad and all that stuff
you know i think one of the things that
i have to sort of figure out going
forward i mentioned this the other day
is like how much i know a lot of you
want to ask me questions about about
fatherhood and about justin and how our
life has changed and how it's changed
some of my thoughts and all that and the
fact that we're having another kid in a
couple weeks and i have to figure out
the blend between how much i want to do
that sort of publicly uh on the show
versus a little more privately in the
locals community i've been leaning
toward that i just think that's that's
just a little bit better uh all right
couple comments from the locals
community tony says biden is jar jar
binks someone else is palpatine right
it's like
right so jar jar remember what happened
with jar jar do i have to tell you the
whole story of the prequels but padme
has to get going she sends jar jar in
jar jar makes the vote that then gets
palpatine the emergency powers yadda
yadda yadda a little lightning force
mace windu his face the whole thing and
then he's got all these powers and he's
the supreme leader that was pretty good
um yeah but who is palpatine that's the
question so is it obama is it susan rice
like is it the clinton machine it just
ain't coming from him it ain't coming
from him and i'm telling you guys if you
think the speeches are bad it's not that
they're bad if they're designed to be
bad if you think the optics are bad it's
not that they're bad they're designed to
be bad and once you see it you will be
empowered and you will realize it and
you will make whatever adjustments in
your life you got to make amy says i'm
pretty sure that if you could look into
joe biden's brain
there would be those austin powers 60
go-go dancers and a psych and
psychedelic music on repeat i'm pretty
sure it would just be a monkey it would
just be a monkey with a tambourine like
flipping like from the simpsons that's
what happens when homer with marge is
talking too much and there's just like a
monkey just doing the flips yeah i mean
there's just not much going on there
man says after watching biden everyone
who loves this country should realize
it's time for us all to unite and get
these
woke left hating people out of office
while we still have a country i mean
that's the irony
it's ever it's sort of it's everyone
versus the woke but then but then you
have to extrapolate what that is it's
everyone versus the woke the
corporations that are put pushing the
woke and then the politicians
who just want more and more and more and
and the fact that that there are people
i mean i don't know what you do about
this that there are people walking
around that i suppose watched that
speech and thought it was either
unifying or good or believe
or believe the stuff that he's saying
about the mag of republicans and all
that it's it's nuts and look i could do
the flip version of that right like i
make fun of the lefties all the time i
think that there are genuine socialists
in the united states government and the
squad and all of those things but i'm
not demonizing the 81 million people i
think let's say let's say there's
probably
20 million people who are like hardcore
lefty sort of crazy socialists now i'm
not for jailing them or put you know
pushing them out of the country or
anything it's like you have to sort of
mock and expose okay fine but then you
have this huge swath of people
who are misguided who are confused i
used to be one of them right i was a
lefty too and you have to wake them up
and the problem is and this is why the
censorship and we're going to do much
more on censorship tomorrow because we
couldn't get to it today um but this is
why censorship is so important to these
people the more that people wake up the
more that they're like wait a minute
these dark mega republicans actually are
kind of nice and they're the ones that
are holding the flag while the other
guys are burning the flag and joe
biden's rhetoric is actually far
dangerous far more dangerous than donald
trump's rhetoric like once you see that
trick well then what do they have left
they can either scare you more monkey
pox 7 covet 9 or they can censor you and
i think the censorship thing is about to
ramp up in a
major way which is a good time for me to
remind you that if you're watching this
on youtube right now i would i would
kindly ask that you jump over to
rumble.com ruben report and follow us on
rumble or go to
reubenreport.locals.com and find us over
there where i can directly get to you
guys without algorithmic manipulation we
know when you subscribe to our videos
you're not seeing them the the
recommended videos are a mess it's like
all of the stuff is a mess but if you
keep playing monopoly when you know that
the banker is stealing money then it's
on you so we're trying to figure out
other things and that's what we're
building with rumble and locals and much
more uh reminder the the interview with
jared kushner which i referenced earlier
comes out at 1 15 today on rumble and on
youtube uh it's already up over on
locals in the blaze and uh now we've got
a cold close for you i feel this was a
good start to the week and i will see
you
tomorrow
america needs cnn to be strong i believe
the free world needs a cnn to be strong
and it will continue to be
because all of us are going to help make
that happen
[Music]
the free world
needs a reliable source
so for reliable sources for the last
time i'm brian stelter
thanks for being with us
[Music]